Let's picture a very realistic scenario.
You're in the middle of processing a
critical payment transaction and
suddenly your server needs to restart
for a deployment. Someone pushed
something to the production environment
and your server needs to deploy itself.
And of course, we have uh techniques
like zero downtime deployment etc. which
makes sure that our existing server does
not go down before our new server, the
server with our new code comes up and is
ready to receive traffic. Those
mechanisms are there. But at some point
when our new server is ready to go
online, is ready to receive traffic, our
old server has to shut down. It has to
stop receiving traffic and the
transition will happen to the new
server. During that moment we are
talking about that part that critical
moment and you are in the middle of a
transaction. Let's say you are in the
middle of a e-commerce transaction you
are buying something from Amazon or
Flipkart and Amazon server or Flipkart
server needs to restart for some kind of
deployment. Now the question is what
exactly happens to that payment and does
it get lost in the digital world or does
the customer you do you get charged
twice because of some kind of race
condition. All these scenarios you have
to think about as a backend engineer and
this is not a new problem. This problem
has been around since the start of
servers and backends. And of course we
already have a solution and that
solution is called graceful shutdown and
it is exactly as the name sounds. We
want to stop our server gracefully. We
don't want to stop abruptly suddenly.
That is the whole idea and of course
there are some surrounding concepts some
surrounding concepts to understand so
that you have your foundations clear why
we are doing this etc. So if we want to
oversimplify what graceful shutdown
means for our server, it we can
basically say that we want to teach our
server, we want to teach our back end
good manners in the sense cannot stop
abruptly when it is between a transition
into a new deployment. It has to perform
some kind of steps, some kind of good
manner in the sense it cannot just slam
the door when it is time to leave, when
it is time to shut down. Instead, your
back end, your application, it politely
finishes whatever it is doing. It
finishes its ongoing conversations, says
goodbye to all the guests and cleans up
after itself, then finally closes the
door. That's what we mean by good
manners. When you have guests over, when
you're talking to them, when it's 9:00,
when it's time to go to sleep, you don't
just push your guests out of the door
and slam the door on their face. There
are some steps you have to perform. So
it's similar in that way. And in this
video, we'll talk about the art and the
science of making your backend
applications as good manner, as
efficient as possible. And worrying
about graceful shutdown will give your
application a very good user experience
and also avoid issues like data
corruption like we just talked about. If
you are in between a transaction some
kind of payment transaction then we can
avoid issues like double charging the
customer and the transaction getting
lost and processing refunds etc. Let's
start with the first concept which is
process life cycle management. Now we
are talking about this because your back
end is an application which will run as
a process in some kind of server in some
kind of computer. So every application
runs in a server within a process. This
is an important thing. It runs within a
process. If you are familiar with
operating system concepts, then uh it
will make sense to you. Otherwise, not a
big deal. You can just learn the term
which is called process. Whatever you
run, everything that runs in an
operating system runs as a process. And
like all the living things, every
process has a life cycle. when it
starts, how it starts, when it ends, and
how it ends. So in a way they're born
when the process starts and they live
while the process is executing and they
die when the process is terminated. This
whole thing is called the life cycle of
a process. Now for implementing or
understanding graceful shutdown, we have
to understand this process life cycle
because that is very closely connected
to how graceful shutdown is implemented.
So this is our OS, the operating system
where our process is running, our
application is running. When your
operating system decides that it's time
for your application to stop running, it
does not just pull the plug, right? It
does not just kill the process. It
follows a established protocol, an
established protocol of communication.
how to communicate with the process to
say that it's time for you to stop and
we are going to follow these these these
steps and then we are going to stop it.
So you can imagine it like a
conversation between your operating
system and your application which is
running inside a process in your
operating system. To simplify it, your
operating system sends a message in the
conversation like hey it's time for you
to stop and your application returns a
message that okay give me a few minutes
or give me a few seconds realistically
speaking then I'll stop myself or you
can stop me and of course this
conversation does not happen through
text we are talking about programs here
so they don't understand text and this
whole communication between your
application and your operating system.
This whole communication this happens
through a concept called signals. Now
signals are an important concept in Unix
operating system. When I say Unix
operating system, we mean all the Linux
operating system whatever you're
familiar with the Arch Linux, Ubuntu
etc. and also Macs. Mac has also
originated from a Unix core a Unix
kernel and mostly when we are talking
about servers we mean Linux only because
99% of the time you'll see uh whenever
we deploy our application in some kind
of server some kind of cloud provider it
usually selects a Linux operating system
and deploys your application there
you'll never see Windows except for some
specialized use cases like Windows
server etc mostly we use Linux based
operating systems for deploying our
servers. Now, Unix operating systems
they have this concept called signals
which is used for IPC. Again, if you are
a computer science students, you'll know
this term is called interprocess
communication. Simply speaking, this is
a technique using which two processes
can communicate with each other with
some established protocol which you
don't have to worry about. Now, the way
it works is you have your application
here, right? It is running inside a
process. This is a process. Your
application is running inside a process
and it registers some handlers. And what
do we mean by handlers? Handlers are
basically uh you can imagine some kind
of code which waits and which is
continuously running behind the scenes
and it is waiting for a waiting for some
kind of communication some kind of
signal from your application for these
signals right these operating system
concepts of communicating between two
processes these are called signals and
your application registers creates some
kind of handlers that detects
Whenever these signals come and then it
does something and we'll talk about what
it does exactly and these handlers they
basically say that they're basically
telling to your operating system that
when you want me to stop send me this
specific message. Of course you cannot
say that just stop. That does not work.
It is text which is just human readable.
So it has to be some kind of message.
We'll talk about what kind of message it
is. that your handlers your application
using or through its handler saying that
whenever you want me to stop you have to
send me this specific message and I'll
handle it appropriately. I'll handle
I'll stop myself using predefined
protocols using predefined steps. Let's
talk about these signals. What do I
mean? There are two major types of
signals we'll talk about but one is sig
term and the second one is sig kill this
part this sig this basically means
signal this also means signal and these
are the commands you can say one is for
termination one is for cl we'll soon
talk about what is the difference
between them now let's talk about the
first one which is sig term now as I
said sig the first part means obviously
signal and the second part means
terminate terminate Now sick term signal
which means terminate. It is a polite
way for your operating system to ask
your application to shut down. It is not
an extreme way. It is just a some kind
of nudge. So imagine you are standing
and someone just comes from behind and
just pokes at your shoulder like hey you
can imagine the sigtom signal something
like that. It is a very gentle nudge and
it means that whenever your operating
system sends a s term signal to your
application it means that hey excuse me
could you please finish up and leave
right it is a very gentle request and
because of that your application your
back end has an opportunity to complete
whatever it is already doing right it it
it does not have to leave that moment
only it has some kind of window we'll
talk about what kind of window it has
some kind window a few seconds to
complete whatever it is doing. Now what
it might be doing? So since we are
talking about back end an HTTP back end
it might be processing some requests
that is the primary thing your back end
does your client your front end whatever
your client have some kind of app some
kind of web app some kind of chrome
extension whatever your client is it
sends HTTP requests to your back end and
your back end processes those and
returns some kind of response at a
random point of time your back end is
probably processing let's say 10 or 12
requests And if your application is big
enough, let's say it is processing
around 500 or 600 requests concurrently
at one point of time. So when it gets a
sdum signal, it's time for it to finish
processing those requests. Let's write
it down whatever it does. First, finish
existing requests. That's the first
thing. Second, clean up resources. We'll
talk about what does cleanup actually
mean for your back end. And the third is
exit. Now we'll talk about we'll go deep
into one and two just a bit after we
talk about both summ. But for now let's
just keep it very high level. Now we
already understood that sik term is a
very gentle request from your operating
system to your application to your back
end to finish up whatever it is doing
and clean up resources and leave
gracefully. So who exactly uses this
kind of signal? Now this signal is
mostly used by deployment systems or
process managers or orchestration
platforms like Kubernetes etc. Basically
any kind of system that you have
established for managing your process.
It can be a Kubernetes or something like
systemd or or PM2 if you are familiar
with PM2 process manager. So these
things these systems these tools they
use this signal which is sig term to
properly let your application finish
whatever it is doing and clean up and
leave gracefully. Second I forgot about
another important signal which is sig
int. We have the kind of signal which is
second as I said the first part this is
called signal and this is for this case
is an interrupt an interrupt. Now when
does this happen? If you are a developer
you probably already using this which is
the most famous use case of this signal
is control + c. If you have worked with
any kind of command line applications,
any kind of terminal based applications
then you have most probably used this uh
some kind of process is running some
kind of task is running and if you want
to abruptly close it at that moment you
can press Ctrl C in your keyboard and
that process is instantly stopped. Say
for example here I am running a back end
a backend process in my local of course
it is a go based back end and this is
currently running it is ready to accept
request and it is serving any kind of
client that is sending request to it now
if I want to close it what do I do I
just press control and c in my keyboard
and here you can see that we have of
course implemented graceful shutdown for
this application that's why we are
logging whatever is happening in our app
but For now, let's focus on this part
where it says that a signal has been
received and the signal type is an
interrupt signal. As we saw, this
requires a user a developer to press
some key in this case control C using a
keyboard. This is mostly used during
development environments. We as
developers mostly use it process to
process communication. when process to
process communication is happening they
normally don't use it since a sig
interrupt based signal uh requires some
kind of key press control C. So it is
also called a user initiated shutdown
and in pretty much all the cases you
want to handle the signal sig int the
same way you are handling sig turn. If
you think about it, it makes sense. It
does not matter whether your process,
whether your back end is running in a
development environment in your local
and you want to stop it using Ctrl C
versus if it is running in your cloud
provider in let's say it is running
inside an AWS EC2 instance and you are
using a process manager called PM2 is a
process manager and you have deployed
your back end in a EC2 instance. So when
there is time to stop your application,
you'll be using PM2 in some kind of
programmatic way or manually. And PM2
will send a signal to your back end
which will be SIG term signal. As I
said, sig int signal will be used by
developers because it requires a key
press. Sig term signal will be used by
programs. In both these cases, we will
want to handle our shutdown process the
same way. It does not really matter if a
human is initiating it or a program is
initiating it. The what matters is the
intention we want to shut down. So we
want to shut down in a clean way, a
graceful way. Now let's talk about the
final thing which is let's write it in
red since it is a kill signal which is
sig kill. As I said the first part means
signal and the second part is the actual
command which is a kill command and it
is exactly as it sounds like we want to
instantly kill the application. The
interesting thing about this signal is
this cannot be caught or it cannot also
be ignored which means that in our
application we cannot register some kind
of handler and those handlers will be
able to do some kind of tasks. they will
be able to do some kind of cleanup etc
etc when they receive s kill signal that
will not happen because this particular
kind of signal it cannot be detected by
our application our application is not
given that kind of permission right that
kind of capability or also it cannot be
ignored which means that you cannot say
since I was not able to detect it which
basically means that I'll just ignore it
we don't have to really stop that also
does not happen. So if your application
is sent a kill signal, it will not be
able to detect it and it has to stop at
that particular moment. Nothing else
happens. It just stops. That's why it is
called a kill signal. You can imagine it
as a nuclear option. This is the
equivalent of instead of doing this,
clicking on your system icon and
clicking on shutdown, you what you do,
you just go to your power plug and you
just pull the plug. That's it. Your
computer just dies. That is exactly how
signal works. And this is why graceful
shutdown is an important concept. If you
don't respond, if you don't respect the
polite signals and what do I mean by
polite signals? Sit term and sing int.
These are the polite signals which let
you to finish whatever you are doing
which let you to clean up and which let
you to gracefully exit. If you don't
respect those signals then eventually of
course you will receive a kill signal.
So you will have to stop and you don't
even get the opportunity to clean up
after yourself. Now that we have a very
high level idea about uh three different
kinds of signals the polite signals, the
impolite signals and what exactly
happens. Let's talk about two important
things here that we briefly talked
about. The first one is what does it
mean by finishing existing requests and
what does it mean by cleaning up
resources. Right? These are the two
important steps which happens during a
graceful shutdown process. The first
important part of a graceful shutdown
which is stopping on the-fly request.
What do we mean by on the-fly requests?
Your HTTP server your back end it is
able to cater to or it is able to
process multiple requests at the same
time or concurrently basically. So when
it is time to stop your back end, when
it is time to stop your server, at that
point it is possible that your back end
is already processing a couple of
requests. Now it can be 10, 12 or it can
be hundreds or it can be thousands
depending on the scale of your server.
And that's what you mean by on the-ly
requests. The requests which are already
getting processed by your server at a
particular time. Now to understand this,
you can imagine a restaurant. Let's say
you have gone to a restaurant with your
friends and for some reason the
restaurant has to close whether it is
time for it to close it is the closing
time let's say something like 10:30 11
in the night or some other reason but
the point is the restaurant has to close
what exactly happens the the restaurant
owners they cannot just come up and turn
all the lights off and they cannot just
throw you out of the restaurant right
not a good idea instead what happens the
restaurant owners they will Ask someone
at the reception or at the gate to stop
allowing new customers, right? Stop
allowing new people to get into the
restaurant first. That's the first step
that happens. You don't want new
customers that you have to deal with
that you have to say no to. First thing
that you have to take care of. Second
thing is they will announce to all the
existing customers, all the existing uh
people in the restaurant who are already
having their meal. They'll announce to
them that it is time for us to close up.
You have let's say 15 minutes, 20
minutes so that you can finish your
meal. Take your time. 15 20 minutes
should be more than enough to finish
whatever you're having and then please
leave the restaurant, pay your bills, of
course, pay your bills and pay your tips
and leave the restaurant. That's exactly
how it plays out in this situation. Now
imagine the same situation for our back
end for our application and we call that
process as connection draining which
means that when your application
receives a shutdown signal. Now it can
be sig term sent from some kind of
process or it can be a sig int sent from
a control c based process from some kind
of developer. Right? The first thing
that it has to do is stop accepting new
connections. As I said, the first thing
that you have to do is stop letting new
customers get into the restaurant. Same
way, the first thing your application
has to do is stop accepting new
connections, which makes the whole
situations more messy, more difficult to
deal with. That's the first thing. stop
accepting new connections, new requests
from any kind of client so that we can
deal with the existing connections, the
existing requests that are already being
processed by our server and we let them
finish as soon as possible. Now the
implementation of connection draining
this will obviously be different
depending on the architecture of the
application that we're dealing with. So
for example for HTTP servers for our
back end the core back end the HTTP back
end this will mean that it has to stop
accepting new HTTP requests from any
kind of client and allow inflight
requests on the fly requests the
existing requests to finish to complete.
The same way if we are talking about a
database application now as we have
already discussed in the previous videos
database is also a backend it can be
imagined as a back end. It is a back end
just not in the sense that we talk about
when we are talking about an HTTP back
end but it is still a back end. It is it
is still an application. Now for a
database based application what it has
to do it has to finish all the existing
queries or all the existing transactions
and it has to stop taking new
transaction or taking uh new queries
into execution before it closes the
connection. Same way for a websocket
based connections it has to first notify
the clients that it is closing then
close the socket. It cannot just close
the socket abruptly. So depending on the
application architecture HTTP back end
database websocket the the technical
steps of implementing graceful shutdown
will be different but the highle idea is
the same. Stop accepting new
connections. Stop accepting new
requests. finish the existing ones and
then close the connection. Three-step
process. Now, the problem here is the
challenge with connection draining is
the timing of it because you want to
give the existing connections enough
time to complete their work but you
cannot really wait as long as they need.
There should be some kind of limit. So
most production systems, most backend
systems, they will implement some kind
of timeout mechanism will have some kind
of timeout. For example, 30 seconds or
let's say 60 seconds. It depends on you.
Mostly the common thing is 30 seconds.
And this will be the maximum duration
your system will wait for you. After
that, we'll just stop, right? We'll give
you 30 seconds to finish whatever
requests that you are processing. And
most of the time, it is fine if you're
not accepting new requests. If you're
not accepting new connections, then 30
seconds should be more than enough to
finish up all the existing requests. But
if for some reason for some kind of
blocking operation, you cannot finish
within this window, then we'll be
forcefully stopped. We do have a backup
plan. We cannot just wait for our system
for our back end to process all the
requests and by taking as long as it
needs, right? We cannot let that happen.
There has to be some kind of limit and
the timeout is that hard limit. you have
exactly this amount of time to finish
whatever you are doing. Now choosing
this timeout also creates a very
interesting design consideration because
the question is how long exactly should
you wait. If it is too short then you
risk interrupting actual legitimate
operations. But if it is too long your
whole shutdown process it becomes very
sluggish and it it eventually impacts
your deployment speed your system
responsiveness. So the time the amount
of timeout it depends on your
application's typical request duration
and your operational requirements. So
this is not a hard and fast rule 30
seconds 60 seconds you have to
understand your systems the kind of
requests that you are processing if it
is normal if you are talking about
traditional normal back end then 30
seconds should be more than enough but
we are talking about websockets or if we
are talking about other more complicated
architectures then you have to
understand your system and decide a
timeout which suits you and your system
accordingly. This whole connection
training also requires some kind of
coordination between your load balancers
and your service discovery systems which
means that it also has to work with your
health check systems and registering and
dregistering with your service
discovery. Now these are a little
advanced stuff. Service discovery
basically means that if you have
deployed a set of applications let's say
your backend your database your elastic
search instance after deployment how
they connect with each other how they
communicate with each other this part of
the workflow is the responsibility of
your service discovery tool service
discovery mechanism anyway moving on the
second thing that we talked about is
cleanup or resource cleanup if you are
working on your desk You have a working
area and it is time for you to leave the
house or it is time for you to go to
sleep. Before you leave your desk, you
do some kind of clean up, right? If you
have been having your coffee, you take
out the cup and put it in the sink or if
you manage some of our cables, etc.,
etc., like we all have some kind of tiny
cleanup stuff before we leave our desks.
Same in the context of our backend
application. When we say resources, it
means that things like file handles or
network connections or database
connections or temporary files or caches
or any other system resources that the
application had acquired during its
execution, it has to let go of those.
For example, uh when your application
was running, when your back end was
running, you tried to access a
particular location in your file system.
And the way file system access works
with back end with programs is you have
to send a signal to your operating
system. It provides you a handle to that
file. There is a protocol the way a
process a backend application can access
the underlying file system. But speaking
at a very high level, you get a kind of
handle to your file system which you
have to let go which you have to clean
up at some point otherwise that handle
will keep running and you will acquire
more and more and more memory which
basically means that you'll keep eating
your RAM random access memory and at
some point you will run out of it.
Right? So cleaning up after your file
handles is important. But the most
common kind of resource cleanup that
we'll see is cleaning up after a network
connections. The our operating system or
OS which is the mediator. Let's say you
have your application here or your back
end here and this is the internet. You
receive all kind of requests but all the
requests they go through your operating
system before it reaches your
application. Your operating system which
is the actual driver which receives all
the requests from your network card and
provides you right. So obviously it it
will have all the knowledge about all
the network connections that you have
and typically operating systems they
limit the number of file handles as I
already said and also network
connections a particular process can
have open simultaneously. The same way
if you don't clean up your file handles
you will run out of memory. The same way
network connections also if you don't
give up a network connection after
dealing with it then eventually you will
run out of memory or you will face some
kind of performance issues. If we are
talking about database connections
before your application shuts down or
before your backend process is shut down
the database transactions that your
backend was dealing with they either
have to be committed or rolled back
explicitly by your application. If you
don't then those transactions might get
into an inconsistent state which might
lead to things like deadlocks or data
corruption and all different kinds of
issues. Right? These these are things
that we mean when we say resource
cleanup file handles, database
connections, network connections etc.
And one thing to keep in mind is when we
are cleaning up after our resources in
our whole graceful shutdown workflow, we
want to clean up resources in the
reverse order of the way we acquired
them. So let's say here you established
a radius connection, then you
established your DB connection and
whatever. So when you are giving up your
resources, you should go the reverse
order. And why do we need to do this? So
that we can prevent situations where we
are not cleaning up a resource. We are
not cleaning up an operation which
depends on the previous operation.
Right? That's the reason we clean up the
resources in the reverse order of the
way we acquired. Right? That is another
thing that you have to keep in mind when
you are implementing your graceful
shutdown. I know that we typically avoid
looking at code in this particular
series. But just to give you some kind
of context, you don't have to understand
this code. I just want to show a pretty
practical and realistic example so that
we don't have just a very hollow
understanding of the graceful shutdown
procedure. Now we'll quickly just go
through the whole thing that we just
discussed. But this time we'll just look
at the code. Now as I said the first
thing that you do is we want to register
some kind of handler which will wait for
some kind of signals. So this is what we
are doing. Again this is a golang code.
You don't have to understand it. You
just follow the narrative and that's
more than enough. Now here at this step
we are registering a handler during
using some kind of context which is a
golang concept but we are waiting for
interrupts from our operating system.
And if we receive an interrupt we call
this function which is a shutdown
function which is a graceful shutdown
function. And what do we mean by
gracefully shutdown? Let's go inside
this. What do we see first? What we are
doing? We are shutting down our HTTP
server. Since this is a back end
application, the core part of this is
the HTTP engine. The first thing that
we're doing is we are calling a method
which is provided by our frameworks.
Typically, whatever framework, whatever
library that you are using for your HTTP
server, they provide you with some kind
of function so that when you call it,
they internally the library internally
stops receiving additional connections
and cleans up and finishes whatever the
existing connection it has. Then this
function finishes. Then what we doing?
we are closing our database. Same way
the database also it stops receiving
additional queries, additional
transactions and it finishes the
existing ones and it gives up whatever
handle it has, whatever database
connections it has. As you already know
the way our backend and our database
connect is through TCP through TCP
connections. You can imagine this is our
app, this is our back end and this is
our database right kind of database. The
way these can connect is through TCP.
This is the TCP protocol. So for our
back end to connect to our database, it
has to have a TCP connection which is an
active connection running. That's the
only way our back end can connect to our
database. It can communicate with our
database. Of course when we are talking
about pooling database pooling we have a
number of these connections active with
our database and we use a particular
connection from this pool of connections
to communicate with our database. When
we want to close the database
connections the database first has to
stop accepting new queries using these
connections using these paths. It will
finish whatever existing queries
existing transaction that is already
processing. Then we'll start closing all
these paths one by one. That is exactly
what we mean by cleaning up our database
resources and in the end we are also
cleaning up our background job
processing server which is using radius.
So internally this function also closes
our radius connection and after all this
we have successfully gracefully shut
down. So if you want to take a look at
this, let's say, let me just clear this
and let's start our server first task
run and let me press Ctrl C which will
send an interrupt signal to our back
end. Then it can initiate the graceful
shutdown procedure. So I pressed Ctrl C.
It took some time since there are no
in-flight requests. This is a pretty
locally run back end. It was able to
shut down instantly but it still we saw
that it still took around 1 second of
time before it could properly shut down.
So if you look at the logs we can see
that for starting our server we the logs
were connected to the database starting
our background job server and finally we
started our server. This was our start
log up to this point. All of this were
our start logs. Then at this point as
you can see the control C here when we
pressed our control C the first thing
that we did is we closed our database
connection closed our database
connection we stop our background job
processing server all these logs are
coming from async Q which is the
background job processing library that
we we are using so when it received the
shutdown signal when we called the
method which shuts down all the radius
connections whatever that it internally
does it also logged some messages like
starting gracefully shutdown waiting for
all workers to finish all workers have
finished and exiting and finally we log
a message that the server has exited
properly and that's how we stop our
server so this whole workflow is called
the process life cycle starting and the
running phase and the stopping phase and
this part is called the graceful
shutdown procedure this is very
important especially when we are
deploying our applications when we don't
want to risk corrupting our inflight
requests and corrupting our workflows,
any kind of workflows and providing a
very good a very delightful user
experience to our customers to our
users. So that's pretty much all you
need to understand about graceful
shutdown. You don't really have to
understand the code because most
probably you'll be using some kind of
library some kind of framework can be
nodej can be go it can be rust and
python and most of the frameworks they
have these code available which you can
just copy and paste for implementing the
graceful shutdown workflow. But it is
important that you understand what
exactly happens when you do gracefully
shutdown and why it is important. That's
why we talked so much about it in this